yesterday afternoon I got back from just
a beautiful bike ride here in the city
of Boston and I was not planning on
doing a live stream until our chess
tournament later at night but it was
announced that Donald Trump called an
urgent press conference set to start at
5 p.m. Eastern yesterday and this was
pretty unusual it hadn't been on the
schedule for the entire day and it was
framed as urgent and potentially
bringing some kind of big announcement I
decided to do a live stream because if
there's something major that's going to
happen let's see what it is and share it
with the audience and we wondered maybe
they were announcing a second stimulus
package maybe there's some kind of big
announcement related to coronavirus what
could it be it seems like something big
is going on so I did a live stream and
clearly news of this urgent press
conference spread widely because instead
of having our normal six to eight
thousand viewers on YouTube we had more
than 40,000 people watch the live stream
concurrently across our platforms and it
ended up being more than an hour of
Donald Trump wildly and belligerently
attacking Joe Biden in a completely
incoherent manner followed by taking
just three questions not really
answering any of them and one of those
three questions came from the outrageous
propaganda right-wing news outlet Oh a n
and this was actually so insane and so
unprecedented that even Fox News anchor
Brett Beier had no choice but to mention
listen Barack Obama did this Barack
Obama called an urgent press conference
at the White House and delivered what
was essentially a campaign speech
attacking his opponent even if it was a
poor campaign speech Republicans would
have lost their minds
saying it's an abuse of power it's an
abuse of the status of the White House
here is Bret Baier actually being honest
and saying it spoke for 52 minutes
before taking a question presidents in
the past by tradition have stayed away
from overt campaign rhetoric from the
Rose Garden or the White House but it is
the president's discretion it is worth
noting however to be fair that had
President Obama made this kind of speech
from the Rose Garden Republicans on
Capitol Hill would likely have been up
in arms but this comes 112 days 16 weeks
to the day before Election Day even
Brett Bay a real
Liza's this was hugely outrageous and
republic Republicans are major
hypocrites now of course there are
people talking about the legal question
like is this using taxpayer money for
campaigning in the sense that this was
really a campaign event where the focus
was attacking Trump's opponent but it
was at the White House with the White
House press corps not campaign people
covering the campaign but as good of an
argument as that might be
I just wouldn't focus much on it because
it's going nowhere the focus really
should be that this is a very desperate
Donald Trump that clearly nobody around
him can control and I know that Trump
has a lot of very bad people around him
whose instincts are terrible but it's
hard to imagine that even they would be
supportive of this it genuinely seems
like on a whim sometime around 4:00 p.m.
Eastern yesterday Trump said put
together a list for me of things I can
say about Joe Biden and let's call an
urgent press conference and then I'm
just gonna go out there and read the
list and that's how poorly it came off
Trump was asked about the fact that his
polling is in the toilet and Trump
mentioned you know there are some
Floridians with boats who seem to like
me I'm not kidding that was Trump's
answer to one of the few questions he
took I don't I think we have really good
poll numbers they're not suppression
polls they're real polls you look at the
intercoastal in Florida you look at the
lakes you see thousands of boats with
Trump signs American signs you've got
the Trump pin sign all over you look at
what's going on you look at bikers for
miles and miles writing up highways
proudly with their signs
thousands of boat owners in Florida love
Trump that's his answer when faced with
polling data and discrediting the polls
by saying they're suppression polls
Trump wildly after stumbling over an
acronym claims that Joe Biden wants to
end the suburbs take a look abolish in
the suburbs you're going to abolish the
separation with this enforce Obama
Biden's radical AFF H that's the AFF H
regulation that threatens to strip
localities of federal affordable housing
funds unless they change
zoning laws to fit the federal
government's demands so what you have I
mean I've been watching this for years
in Westchester coming from New York
they want a low-income housing built in
a neighborhood well I'm ending that rule
I'm taking it out so I'd spoke with ben
Carson the other day we're gonna be
taking it out I've watched that whole
thing go and now they want to make it
twice as bad in the suburbs in the
suburbs
mothers aren't happy about that fathers
aren't happy about that they worked hard
to buy a house and now they're going to
watch the housing values drop like a
rock and that has happened Trump just
barely able to get through the reading
but says Joe Biden wants to end the
suburbs just kind of aimlessly stumbling
around here's just like a random 60
seconds where you'll notice Donald Trump
is just jumping from topic to topic with
no rhyme or reason making absolutely no
sense and I believe this is the clip
where you get a shot of the press and
they're just still there like statues
they don't know what the hell is going
on many countries and I did this myself
for the most part not to use Huawei
because we think it's an unsafe security
risk it's a big security risk
I talked many countries out of using it
if they want to do business with us they
can't use it just today I believe that
UK announced that they're not going to
be using it and that was up in the air
for a long time but they've decided and
you look at Italy you look at many other
countries we withdrew from the Chinese
dominated WHL and we fully rebuilt the
United States military the WHL World
Health Organization we were paying close
to five hundred million dollars a year
China was paying 39 million dollars a
year and China had too much say they
worked it very hard which is a bad thing
done by our past administrations but we
were tough and we're saying I was asking
I said why are we paying so much more
than China
just all over the place I mean really
really bizarre just one other clip for
you here here Donald Trump claims that
this is so crazy
he claims that Joe Biden is against
windows like now I'm not talking about
the Windows operating system he's not
saying Joe Biden's a Mac guy he's saying
if Joe Biden were president buildings
wouldn't have windows heating cooling or
lighting mandate net zero carbon
emissions for homes offices and all new
buildings by 2030 that basically means
no windows no nothing it's very hard to
do I tell people when they want to go
into some of these buildings how are
your eyes because they won't be good in
five years and I hope you don't mind
cold office space in the winter and warm
office space in the summer because your
air conditioning is not the same as the
good old days this is so crazy and it
reminds me of what I think at this point
I don't know if it was like six months
ago or a year ago remember that rant
where Donald Trump said Democrats don't
want you to have good flushing toilets
likes it's just stuff about water
pressure and saying just really really
bizarre so what we had here in the end
is that Donald Trump manipulated
reporters to get them to go to the White
House to rant to them about Joe Biden
and if I was on the fence about voting
for Trump I mean listen I know that if
you're in the tank for Trump
you don't care you probably didn't even
watch this in fact there's a lot of
crumpets who in order to avoid being
confronted with his incompetence no
longer even watch Trump's public facing
events they're just voting for Trump
they don't want to hear anything else
about it if you were already not voting
for Trump obviously this press
conference this ranting is not going to
convince you to vote for Donald Trump
I'm imagining even though I don't really
get how anyone could be undecided at
this point if you were one of these
undecided voters could this possibly
convince you to vote for Donald Trump
and if
again I don't know how anyone is
undecided I'm not sure if there's any of
these undecided voters in my audience
but if you are one of those people I
would love to hear your perspective on
Trump calling an urgent press conference
at the last second and then struggling
to read criticisms of Joe Biden off of
his pieces of paper it is very very
bizarre before we go to a break
I do have kind of a cool announcement as
some of you know I am a very bad amateur
chess player and over the last few
months we've engaged with our audience
by occasionally running a chess
tournament we had one last night with
728 players it was a great time
apparently word of my amateur chess
playing has gotten around and I have
been invited by chess comm to be one of
16 participants in a chess tournament
next month called the pogchamp stew
pogchamp one was last month grandmaster
Hikaru Nakamura reached out to me I said
I would love to do it
the chess comm team reached out to me I
said I would love to do it so that's
where we are right now I have been
assigned excellent professional chess
player coaches to coach me from the
standpoint of being a participant in
this tournament and I am probably going
to be doing most of the coaching
sessions over on Twitch and the first
one is tonight at 8:30 p.m. Eastern so
this is not going to be like the normal
oh my Sharpie is collapsing this is not
going to be the normal sort of stream
this is going to be twitch only tonight
at 8:30 and it will be the start of my
journey in preparing for this tournament
that will be taking place in August so
join me tonight on twitch at twitch.tv
slash David Pakman I will be introducing
you to my first of two actually really
three different chess coaches that I'm
going to have I'm that bad that I need
multiple coaches sadly but it'll be a
good time it'll be a nice break from all
the politics tonight so we'll take a
quick break I will see you in just a
couple of minutes but then hopefully
tonight as my chess pogchamp s--
adventure begins one of our sponsors
today is hydrant and they are giving my
audience 25% off
your first order this has been a game
changer for me this is a refreshing
electrolyte powder that you mix directly
into your water to rehydrate your body
because it is packed with the four
essential electrolytes that your body
needs the most that's sodium potassium
magnesium and zinc and because of how
hydrent is formulated it's an efficient
way of getting yourself rehydrated and
it tastes awesome there's a variety of
flavors I have blood orange which I love
you can also get grapefruit and lime a
lot of us don't even realize when we're
dehydrated a lot of the time and it's
become a really great part of my daily
routine if I'm under hydrated I'm
affected physically I'm affected
mentally and I think you never fully
understand this until you use hydrent
for the first time I get a great boost
of energy when I'm properly hydrated if
I've been dehydrated they also have a
version with caffeine which I love if
and when that's what I'm looking for
everyone in my audience gets 25% off
your first order when you go to drink
hydrant calm slash Pakman or just enter
the code Pakman at checkout I've put the
link right underneath this video